bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
climat que nous sommes ici aujourd'hui
sur le campus de saint quentin en
yvelines en compagnie de notre invité
nicolas d'un biberon jour bonjour ans
nicolas dainville vous êtes le maire de
la verrière et vous êtes également le
vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines délégué à
l'emploi à la formation professionnelle
est également à l'apprentissage et
justement on va parler avec vous des
contrats d'apprentissage j'ai quelques
chiffres avec moi à l'échelle nationale
on sait que 718 mille contrats ont été
signés en 2021 ce qui représente une
augmentation de 25% par rapport à
l'année précédente en 2020 comment ça se
passe sur 50 ans et demi c'est à l'image
de justement à la france exactement on a
près de 2000 à alternant donc qui
comprend l'apprentissage à l'échelle du
territoire on a eu effectivement des
aides de l'état qui ont été conséquentes
et qui ont permis à des entreprises
saisir de cette opportunité
c'est un contrat qui est gagnant gagnant
gagnant pour l'entreprise puisque ça
permet de former un jeune et de l'avoir
sur le plus long terme
et puis le gagnant pour le jeune parce
qu'il mêle la théorie à la pratique et
donc c'est le meilleur tremplin vers
l'emploi un emploi durable donc on mise
beaucoup sur saint quentin sur
l'apprentissage et on connaît
effectivement une tendance à la hausse
donc c'est quand même une très bonne
nouvelle pour l'emploi pour l'emploi des
jeunes et ça se poursuit là vous pensé
pour 2022 c'est pareil on est sur cette
pente ascendante bah écoutez les aides
vont se vont se terminer dans quelques
mois peut-être qu'il y en aura d'autres
il faut surtout je pense un changement
des mentalités comprendre peut-être
davantage en s'inspirant de la suisse
font s'inspirant l'allemagne que les
études peuvent vraiment davantage mais
les la théorie en université en école
mais aussi la pratique en entreprise
et je pense que ce changement des
mentalités ya encore du travail mais on
y contribuer en tant qu'élu en tant que
professionnel il faut un changement des
mentalités du côté des jeunes et aussi
du côté des entreprises et des parents
parfois pour inciter les jeunes à opter
pour cette belle voix on va faire venir
vous parler des jeunes justement nous
sommes allés à leur rencontre sur le
territoire saint quentinois nous vous
parlez à des étudiants qui sont eux
aussi en alternance
pour l'alternance c'est que des
avantages
ce qui me plaît dans le fait d'être en
alternance c'est le rythme déjà on est
ainsi l école et puis deux tiers
entreprises donc ça donne un rythme de
vie qui est plutôt sympa ça nous permet
vraiment une meilleure insertion sur le
marché du travail mais surtout ça nous
ça nous construit en tant que
professionnel et âge égal quelqu'un qui
n'aura fait que de l'école n'aura pas du
tout cette ce capital de compétences que
nous on a en sortant d'alternance
d'être dans le monde de l'entreprise
directement avant la fin de mes études
c'est une véritable opportunité ça me
permet du coup d'avoir une meilleure
vision du monde dans l'entreprise on a
des étudiants qui à la fin de leur
formation ne savent pas vraiment vers
quel métier s'orienter la tendance est
avant tout se conforter soi-même dans le
son soit professionnel et puis rien
n'empêche par la suite à la fin d'une
alternance de changer éventuellement de
métier
[Musique]
la formation est payé par l'école donc
c'est un énorme avantage et l'avantagé
également du salaire qui n'est
absolument pas négligeable c'est un
master que je ferai un an et j'avais
besoin que ce soit une formation
accélérée et je pense que la partie
justement alternance donc formation
théorique et pratique permet vraiment
d'accélérer l'apprentissage d'alternance
ça me permet de faire la transition
entre du coup les études et le monde du
travail en me disant bas je passe pas de
l'un à l'autre brusquement ce qui peut
être important pour savoir si on veut
faire date avancée vraiment se poser la
question de est-ce qu'on sent prêt à
s'engager dans une entreprise pour un an
ou deux ans ou est-ce qu'on préférait
prendre son temps et poser un peu les
choses
[Musique]
nicolas d'un biberon sans que l'image
quand même de l'alternance à évoluer
encore on peut dire qu'elle a changé
d'écouté c'est vrai que l'alternance et
l'apprentissage été longtemps cantonnée
à des métiers très manuelle parler de
l'intelligence de la main et aujourd'hui
heureusement il s'ouvre aux de faire de
la banque de la finance du numérique qui
recrutent qui manque cruellement
d'emplois et donc sur saint quentin on
essaye aussi de miser sur ces métiers en
forte tension on a des écoles du
numérique et des entreprises qui
proposent ce type de mélange entre la
théorie et la pratique et c'est du
gagnant gagnant alors justement il ya
vous parler des métiers en attente tous
les métiers sont ouverts l'alternance
c'est vrai il ya des limites quand même
pas écouté la plupart des métiers sont
concernés on peut parler du numérique
l'école de 1600 qui proposent ce type de
contrat on peut parler des écoles de
commerce on peut parler d école
d'ingénieur avec l'estac a on peut
parler des métiers après une formation
universitaire lu vs qq s'inscrit dans la
dynamique de paris saclay donc c'est
vrai que la plupart des grands métiers
aujourd'hui proposent ce type de contrat
ah c'est vrai que voilà il ya une
évolution des mentalités et une prise de
conscience et on ne peut que s'en
féliciter
à ce sujet je vais vous donner quelques
chiffres les bacs plus de son passé de
35% à 56% entre 2016 et 2020 ce qui est
considérable aujourd'hui quels profils
en fait de jeunes sont concernés par
l'alternance l'écouté vous avez des
profils licence vous avez des profils
masters donc il ya vraiment tous les
types de profils
c'est ça vraiment l'intéressé qui en a
pour tous les goûts pour tous les
parcours vous avez cité quelques écoles
dont l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines comment est-ce qu'on
finance un parcours comme ça pour les
jeunes c'est pris en charge c'est
gratuit comment ça marche bah écoutez
vous avez des aides qui sont versés à
l'entreprise qui recrute un jeune en
alternance des aides qui ont été
consolidées augmenté ces derniers temps
ce qui a pu permettre quand même un
certain regain d'intérêt pour les pour
les entreprises
et puis les entreprises donne un salaire
pour le jeune sinon une partie aussi de
ses études donc c'est pris en charge
essentiellement par le monde privé avec
des aides de l'état justement on va
aller les voir on va aller du côté de la
drh la direction des ressources humaines
ils vont vous expliquer pourquoi cet
intéressant pour eux de recruter ces
profils en alternance
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous avons un peu plus de
quinze alternance à nantes et mais tard
nous projetons d'en recruter dix
nouveaux pour la rentrée de septembre
en termes de proportion nous sommes
plutôt sur sept pour cent des effectifs
beaucoup de métiers liés à
l'informatique qui sont assez pénuriques
aujourd'hui face à ce contexte de
pénurie aujourd'hui l'alternance est un
des moyens de recrutement
[Musique]
accueillir des apprentis ça peut nous
garantir dans des embauches à la clé
parce que va le marché du travail et
rechercher des candidats qui
correspondent à nos attentes ça reste
compliqué donc avoir un peu plus de
temps et former des personnes via
l'apprentissage c'est un gain de temps
et d'argent pour pour la société c'est
hyper intéressant pour un apprenti en
plus sur plusieurs années de trois ans
comme ne peut avoir ici pour monter
vraiment compétents sur l'ensemble de la
fonction aujourd'hui nous pouvons
recruter des profils seniors des profils
confirmés nous avons également besoin
d'avoir des jeunes diplômés pour une
raison simple c'est concerne une
entreprise il faut tous niveaux
d'expérience pour pouvoir donner un
parcours professionnel à l'ensemble de
ses collaborateurs et des trajectoires
l'alternance va nous permettre de
formé de manière très précise et très
pointu les jeunes sur nos spécificités
donc effectivement
c'est pour nous une manière de modeler
entre guillemets des jeunes à nos savoir
faire à nos technologies à nos
expertises et donc c'est une valeur
extrêmement précieuse pour nous
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
notre invité nicolas dainville mais nous
nous trouvons à présent devant l'estaca
alors je vais vous demander nicolas
dainville vous êtes également délégué de
saint quentin en yvelines à l'emploi la
formation professionnelle et bien sûr
l'apprentissage qu'est ce qui vous plaît
dans cette attribution des écoutes et
c'est une attribution qui est
passionnante parce que
on essaye d'aider concrètement des
jeunes à trouver leur voie trouver leur
place en entreprises à réussir leur
orientation leur vie professionnelle
je suis aussi mère et je dois chier mes
concitoyens tout l'intérêt de la
politique saint-quentinoise que nous
menons pour s'orienter au mieux on a une
cité des métiers on a des missions
locales qui permettent aux jeunes voilà
de trouver leur voie on a également une
plateforme qui s'appelle ski emploi.fr
qui permet à chacun de trouver une
entreprise on a des événements pour
permettre aux jeunes et aux moins jeunes
de trouver un emploi je pense à en piste
pour l'emploi une fois par an au
vélodrome national avec près de 3000
offres d'emploi ou encore avec le iiie
job dating consacrée à l'apprentissage
qui se fait aussi une fois par an on en
est à la troisième édition pour
connecter l'entreprise et les jeunes en
recherche de contrat d'apprentissage et
sur saint quentin en yvelines quand
est-ce qu'on voit l'avenir dans ce
secteur de l'alternance bah écoutez on a
des événements d'ampleur mondiale qui
vont se dérouler sur notre territoire on
a les jeux olympiques c'est une fois
dans notre vie qu'on aura la chance de
vivre un tel événement extraordinaire
sur saint quentin en yvelines et donc
forcément il y aura un coup de
projecteur extraordinaire sur notre
territoire il y aura un boost
économiques évidents dans tous les
secteurs dans le milieu de l'hôtellerie
dans l'ue et de la restauration dans le
milieu du sport dans le milieu du
tourisme et et tous ces secteurs là vont
connaître un regain d'activité grâce à
ces événements d'ampleur donc on a je
dirais un territoire qui est bénie des
dieux on a les plus belles entreprises
du monde peut citer airbus on peut citer
thales on peut citer renault on a aussi
des pme des start up qui commence à se
développer qui bénéficie de la dynamique
de paris saclay qui est une des zones de
rayonnement mondial on a un incubateur
space qui cube que l'on a ouvert on
justement booster nos startups nos
entrepreneurs donc on a tout pour
réussir à 50 ans du vélo on parle
d'avenir on justement si vous voulez
bien aller à la rencontre de jeunes qui
ont suivi une formation l'alternance on
les retrouve alors trois ans et on y dix
ans après que sont ils devenus
je regarde que des bons souvenirs et oui
c'est l'alternance qui m'a glissé en
tout cas chez antemeta aujourd'hui après
sept ans je suis toujours là je suis
devenu professionnel à l'âge de 19 ans
l'alternance est venu vraiment porter
mes études ça a accéléré ma carrière ça
m'a permis de prendre conscience de ce
que je voulais faire ou est ce que je
voulais aller on n'était que deux dans
ma dans ma promo à être en contrat
d'apprentissage et on est les seuls à
avoir été après garder pour ma part en
cdi donc c'était vraiment une bonne
porte d'entrée comparativement aux
autres qui étaient en stage dans un
milieu qui est pourtant assez spécialisé
dans le bâtiment moi qui étais vous et
allez dans la culture c'est vrai que
j'étais pas du tout rodez même au jargon
[Musique]
en trois ans et me voilà je suis devenu
je passais d'apprentis à rédactrice en
chef j'ai fait mes preuves pendant ces
deux ans que j'ai fait en alternance
chanter mais tu as qui m'a permis de
créer un climat de confiance avec
l'entreprise évolué comme j'ai pu
évoluer que ce soit dans mon statut ou
ou à ma rémunération j'ai appris j'ai
mûri grâce à cette alternance et à me
sentir importante et utile et nécessaire
dans l'entreprise pour le coup
d'accélération quand on rentre en
entreprise donc vraiment lance sa
carrière
l'alternance est vraiment bénéfique
par contre c'est très dur faut pas se
mentir c'est c'est dur de travailler
pour une entreprise d'être performant
pour l'entreprise et d'être performant
si pour ses études il faut arriver à
jongler des deux côtés
[Musique]
alors si on est un jeune saint
quentinois et qu'on veut qu'on est
intéressé par ce parcours en alternance
qu'est ce que vous nous conseillez
d'écouté il ya déjà le réseau le réseau
de l'université de l'école à laquelle on
appartient qui est la première étape et
puis on a tout un tas d'outils notamment
le site ski emploi.fr qui la porte
d'entrée pour tous ceux qui recherchent
un contrat en apprentissage ou un poste
un emploi c'est vraiment notre porte
d'entrée sur le territoire merci
beaucoup nicolas dainville merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis à très bientôt pour
un prochain numéro de ski mag
[Musique]